[Music]
let's move on to our next brexit
deadlines have come and gone an
agreement has yet
to be reached but they haven't really
got much time now it all has to be done
and
dusted one way or another by the end of
the year and that's
fast approaching we get smoke signals
coming out
almost every week sometimes it looks
like a deal is going to be done
then others look like maybe we're not so
sure so where are we now
i'm joined by james forsyth our
political editor and wolfgang muncher
editor of euro intelligence welcome uh
to you wolfgang to james first
give us an update where we are at the
talks as you see it
so uh today's news is that michelle
barnier was meant to brief
eu member states on what's been going on
he's decided not to do that
that is seen as a positive sign that
they want to keep a lid on what is being
discussed
in these negotiations because they think
they are making some progress and they
think that letting in
you know too much sunlight on it might
not work
i mean negotiations are undoubtedly more
intensive this week
uh simon coveney uh the irish promise
that described it as gonna move weak for
both sides and i think both sides are
moving but i think they are moving in a
crab-like fashion rather than like
gazelles
so i think it's too early to say that
you know oh it's all going to be done
but i think things are definitely
looking more positive than they were
a week or so ago and i think there's
also this which is
i think both sides as you get closer to
this deadline
are beginning to consider the enormity
of what
a no deal would mean and no deal
wouldn't just be an economic event
indeed
i actually think given that this deal is
going to be a relatively
thin deal i think i think i think it's i
mean the consequence of no deal will be
far more geopolitical with economic
and i i struggle to see how it does not
poison
uk eu relations forward for a decade uh
and i think that that would obviously
bleed over into cooperation on you know
foreign policy challenges such as russia
uh uh or you know the western response
to china and the like
so i think i think that kind of the
geopolitical forces are pushing both
sides to do a deal
but you know uh on uh issues of
substance it is still hard and i think
the ultimate question comes down to it
is
you know is if you get more movement on
the level playing field
i i struggle to think that the whole
deal will fail over fish that there
won't be some
way found to kind of massage uh the
fishing question
which is obviously politically emotive
on both sides of a channel
but i think there is a kind of sense
that you know if fish is the last issue
the two sides really ought to be able to
fix that
wolfgang let me pick up another one
james just made there when the british
started these uh negotiations in the
latest round
there was all this talk of you know we
want we are up for canada
plus plus plus you know we want
everything in the canadian free trial
trade deal and a lot
more on services and all the rest of it
it doesn't look good to me wolfgang that
even if we get a deal we'll be anywhere
near that
this is much more likely to be canada
dry than canada plus plus plus
oh it's canada dry and very dry indeed
it's it's a very thin deal i think
people people we
we're talking about the deal versus node
and i agree with james failure to
to to do a deal is indeed um uh
a crisis uh in eu uk relations
especially if it wasn't
acrimonious failure uh as opposed to the
failure where
both sides say you know let's just you
know stop for now and
try again next year and try to do as
little damage in the meantime
there are some mitigating measures both
sides could take
but um you know the deal the deal will
be
thin and i think the big shock for many
people will be when brexit happens and
there is a deal
how how little how little this deal will
comprise now there won't be tariffs
there won't be quotas that is sure some
some achievement
but tariffs are you know three percent
on average
uh okay the average may not be
meaningful because the tariffs on fish
on certain
categories of fish are going to be very
high the terrorism cars are going to be
high
uh there will be very visible tariffs
but on average three percent that's
that's off that's less than a you know a
bad day's exchange rate movements
so this is not going to be the big the
big economic the big economic issue but
people will realize no there isn't a
deal for financial services there isn't
a deal for any other services there may
not be a deal for
even for university degrees and the
recognition of professional
qualifications we
haven't seen the text nobody has really
nobody really knows what is being agreed
nobody's
been able to study the text i know you
know
the people in the european parliament
get very nervous not because time is
running out
but because they feel that they have to
ratify a text that is possibly 1800
pages long
in a week and they may just see things
or discover things as you know
ratification is a meaningful procedure
it's not just a vote
to to they will vote in favor of it but
you know a long text will have
implications for companies
nobody knows what's in it so even if
this is agreed
and you know it could be a very very
messy
a very messy procedure why has it come
to this you know there was talk you know
this could be the greatest free trade
deal
in history the uk economy the eu
eu economy in regulatory terms at the
moment they're totally aligned
the there's the smoothest free trade
between them of any
uh parts of the world so therefore it
shouldn't be that difficult
even though we are leaving to move to a
very ambitious free trade deal
why has that not happened and
probably i know people don't like to ask
questions like this
these days days who's to blame
both sides are to blame the eu misjudged
the brexit process from the start of the
finish and it still
is still misjudging it uh there is
always
it has played too much um into
there was too much hope that the uk
would extend the deadline in july which
he could have done
they didn't believe johnson when he said
he would not extend
they did not expect to be in the
position that they are now that boris
johnson hasn't folded yet which this is
something they expected because the
assumption in brussels has been
the uk needs this deal more urgently
than the eu for that reason
the uk has an interest and conceit in
conceding
some of the points the eu has done some
made some unreasonable demands in the
beginning
like asking or like demanding that the
ecj's continues to play a role
uh like asking the uk to align its
regulatory policies on labor markets
environmental standards
and on state aid to the eu these
negotiations have brought a lot of
progress on these issues so the
differences that we have now in these
negotiations
there are still important differences
but they are not the differences between
good or bad so even if if if the
if one side were to give in more than
the other um
in in in the face that we have achieved
at this point
it wouldn't be a disaster it might just
be a you know bad pr for one side
uh but it it wouldn't be you know it is
a fairly balanced
deal that we have at the moment uh there
are reasonable tradeoffs to make
like on fish i mean the uk wants to sell
fish on the european markets the uk
so there's a lot of fish to spain you
know uk is a country that eats court and
and exports mackerel and spain is a
country that eats mackerel and exports
costs so so
one would assume that the two come to
some kind of sensible agreement given
the given the situation
and on competition policy i have
sympathies with the use point that that
if there is a if you have a large trade
agreement or
a trade agreement with a large trading
partner next door that you want to have
a broad
a broad consensus about state aid and in
fact the uk is not the problem here
germany has far more it gives far more
trade
state aid to companies so this is a bit
of a of a straw man debate i mean the
eu has a massive trade surplus with the
eu and we're talking about a level
playing field issue
in the other direction it doesn't really
make sense you in the uk should be
raising level playing field issues given
that it has a deficit
so so um so in the end we're dealing
with straw man issues that that could in
that should
rationally be resolved the danger now is
not the trade the trade negotiators are
doing a good job they
will identify a landing zone i'm pretty
sure
at some point next week the difficulty
they have
is to ensure that when they come up with
this tradings or this this this uh
landing zone um that the two principals
you know boris johnson in the uk
and you know for all you know probably
immanuel macron on the eu side
will both in the end do the right thing
and not start
to you know extend this and find another
way of
of um or making another unreasonable
demand that the other side would then
expect so an accident that's possible
will it require that if there is to be a
deal at the the 11th hour and it's quite
often the 11th hour these things
happen but will it require
a political intervention at a
nation-state level
and by that i mean will it require
angela merkel
to have to have a quiet word with
emmanuel macron
uh chancellor merkel perhaps with the
backing of the swedes and the dutch and
maybe even the spanish and the italians
as well
i just try and find a way to help him
down from the fish issue
perhaps find ways even of compensating
him in other ways
in other words it will take the the top
nation state leaders in the end
to make some kind of political
intervention if there is a
if this thing is not wrapped up by say
early next week then that will
undoubtedly happen
uh uh mackel will talk mackel never put
the interest of the german never entered
use the german car industry in these
negotiations she never she was
she really stayed out of she prioritized
the unity of the eu
which was an intelligent negotiating
position but macro hasn't done the same
macro
has actually invoked the interest of the
french fishing industry
now the german car industry is a
multitude bigger than the french fishing
industry
so you know michael would have a point
to say to micron i didn't do this but
you are doing this so let's basically be
reasonable and cut a deal here
uh i don't think that germany can
compensate france for the loss of
fishing so that would have to be
negotiated with the uk
and there are ways to negotiate in in
terms of
transitional periods in terms of quarter
arrangements i
you know the uk has enough water there
is no shortage of
there's no shortage of water there's no
food shortage of fish this is a
very strange dispute to have this is not
like we're not really dealing with
serious economic issues here but um but
it's it's mostly perceptional issues
so there should be a deal but i i
completely agree this will not be
decided by the negotiators the
negotiators are preparing the ground
what they're calling landing zones
that's all they can do
and neither lord frost nor mashimi
shelbani are in a position
to force the hand of macon they do
however obviously talk to both sides
and if macron is not at this point not
briefing his people then that's probably
to do with the fact that
he hasn't yet got the clearance for
compromise
they they need to talk they need to they
need to get some more details
uh he he will he you know the french are
recognizing that they need to compromise
on fish in principle they do
but the question is to which extent they
do and whether that is still compatible
with the with the uk position
um so the fish is a serious issue
um that that will that could still
jeopardize the thing it's not a
substantive issue in the sense that you
know we're talking about
one two one one billion or two billion
pounds of of of trade which is minute
compared to the other stuff
you know the fact that we haven't got
anything on financial services is much
much more serious
uh let me go back to james wolfgang for
a minute and then i'll finish up with
you
uh james putting the bravado or the
public face aside
is there not some real concern in
westminster or in whitehall
that there isn't a deal not because the
deal is going to be that great or
actually even if the deal
has a deleterious effect on the economy
it will probably in the short term all
be
hidden by the fallout from covent we're
not really going to be able to measure
now all the economic models were
preparing to measure what was going to
happen
have really been shot to hell because of
covert now we won't really know
what was covered what was no deal brexit
but there's a kind of symbolic
reputational issue for the government
is there not which are along the lines
of you've been useless the handling
covered
and you can't even get a deal on leaving
the eu
yeah i mean there are three big dangers
the first is the geopolitical one
the second thing is not getting a deal
would make the northern ireland
situation much
more difficult and if the uk government
pressed ahead with the clauses in the
internal market bill
that would strain relations with the
incoming biden administration
but i think the biggest issue is is is
your last point on competence andrew
because
i think in the event of a deal you would
see both sides
move to keep trade flowing uh i think
you would see the eu take a relatively
light touch approach to checks
you know let's keep things moving i
think in the event of no deal because i
think
i think no deal would inevitably be to
wolfgang's point but inevitably
acrimonious i can't imagine the two
negotiators shaking hands and saying
well not shaking hands whatever you're
meant to do in this in this in this day
and age
um and saying well let's sit back down
around the table in six months i think
it would be a
political row and a blame game i i think
in that situation
the eu would take a much more uh
fingernail checking approach
to uh border checks uh it's well known
that there are people around emmanuel
macron who take the view that you know
six months of that and the brits will be
back at the table and much more inclined
to compromise on fish
and i think the danger for the
government is people will say
well we voted to leave in 2016 why
wasn't the country
ready for this uh and the other danger
is
you know we voted for you to get brexit
done and now brexit's all over the news
every night again
what's going on wolfgang let me finish
with you and then we're going to move
across the atlantic
uh maybe i suggested my previous
question that maybe angela merkel would
have to intervene at a political level
with the support of others
maybe what would break the log jammer
get us through this given the
geopolitical consequences that james is
talking
about would be an anglo-frank summit of
mr johnson and uh
president macron mr johnson speaks
fluent french
they both like to drink wine together
the french like a british politician
that can speak another language
partly because it doesn't happen very
often and
there are huge anglo-french
relationships at stake here
our intelligence cooperation has never
been greater and france is in the middle
of a huge fight against islamism
a fact that mr macron is taking the lead
the only two militaries that really
matter in europe
are france and britain and britain's
just announced a massive extension of
the money we spend
we have two world-class aircraft
carriers one of which is already being
deployed the other
shortly they could work with france too
there are so
many issues the deployment of force
britain's already helping
uh the french out in mali with heavy
lift capabilities
if there has to be a european
intervention somewhere or another
it'll only be the british and the french
that can really do it
couldn't all these issues if they were
out in the open in the future
you know i know now mi6 is now embedded
with dgse in paris
dgse is now regularly with mi6 in london
shouldn't that matter a lot more than
fish
it would be funny if that all that were
sacrificed at the
uh over a dispute of fish it's it's um
it's one of the strangest debates i
think i've
i have followed but i completely agree
these strategic impacts that you have
all these strategic
relationships that you've mentioned the
you know uk is a member of the u.n
security council is another another
another important issue to to to to
consider from a european perspective
um these are uh points that have
unfortunately not played a role in the
european debate
i would however think that macro
understands this and this is probably
one thing that
mccor understands better than the other
other european leaders
who are more focused on the internal
market and domestic policy issues
macaron too is focused on domestic
policy issues
my reading of his position on fish is
that he is merely
putting up a fight which he needs to do
in france it's important that the
president stands up for the small guy
and he needs to do that if he didn't do
that
others would do this and he has an
election campaign coming up
in 22. so my reading of the situation is
that he will
put up a fight but in the end agree
uh it would indeed be a failure of
french policy
if he didn't and indeed it would be a
disaster for a french fisherman if there
wasn't a deal either
so this is because then they get no
access it wouldn't make sense
the position so so there is a
possibility as you say
a franco uh uk summit is a possibility
i think they might have settled this on
the phone frankly uh the issues are very
clear
uh that in the end they have to both be
seen to be fighting
and and settle this there is an
excellent possibility as they always are
in these negotiations especially since
the eu
has other crises at the moment about the
your budget
of hungary these are issues that are
kind of distracting them at the moment
it could be
that they are you know taking the eye of
the ball
that is quite possible but uh the under
under any normal circumstances there
should be
a deal happening before the end of the
year
the you know it might not even happen
next week the eu has several
mechanisms or it's at least considering
mechanisms
to delay the whole ratification process
for example this thing could go until
christmas
and then they're ratified later that is
a possibility it's not yet fully
explored legally
you know it's it's uncharted territory
but it's not clear that it's
impossible so and they will do anything
to get it to
to they will not let this fail over you
know time is running out that's not
going to be
the issue right we'll come back and uh
mark our card as we reach the end game
with this process it's been a joy to
have you on
spectator tv today wolfgang muncher
[Music]
you